[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je pense que c'est pour ça que les gens sont
théistes à notre sujet, c'est
parce que nous parlons toujours de la
vie des jeunes
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous avons les sept  différentes personnalités
et personnages comme pour moi, j'ai un
rôle de leader, j'écris des chansons
pour eux et tu sais apprendre à
écrire des mélodies pour eux
[Musique] L'
Amérique est comme s'ils étaient, tu sais, le numéro
un du marketing musical pour toi  Je sais où
tout a commencé et avec nous, nous avons
écouté de la musique pop américaine et de la
musique hip-hop quand nous étions comme je
ne sais pas, comme neuf ou dix ans, alors
j'aimerai savoir que certaines attentions en
Amérique signifient tellement pour  nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]